[Music]
college football championship last night
did anyone watch this game that was not
a great game kind of a blowout yeah last
night alabama won the national
championship by defeating Notre Dame 42
to 14 Notre Dame defeated yeah Irish
people haven't been this depressed since
all the time every day constantly good
news for hockey though after 113 days
the National Hockey League has settled
its contract dispute by the way if
you're interested be last time Americans
113 days without watching hockey
it was during last year's hockey season
even hockey fans cheer that Joe Wright
right it is very unpopular no teeth
Governor Chris Christie is taking some
heat this was in the news a political
opponent of New Jersey Governor Chris
Christie is now accusing Governor
Christie of praying for hurricane sandy
yeah
in response Christie said the only
weather-related thing I've ever prayed
for is a Dairy Queen blizzard
it's a quote right there I couldn't lose
you're always thinking hearing about new
courses that colleges are offering it's
a little strange the University of
Arizona is now offering a degree in
hip-hop yeah so far the majors most
popular classes intro to [ __ ] what's
gonna be on the test that would be me in
that class and we're gonna have to know
this so from my notes it says they'd be
crazy
[Applause]
that's correct mr. Richter how often be
they trippin
quite often mr. Richter all right let my
guy teaching the class I'll be teaching
hip hop yes mr. Richter another question
I'm professor scull Bo ladies and
gentleman the oldest woman in America
has died at the age of 114 yeah her last
words were Al Roker did what who knows
what I'm talking about
clearly this is unbelievable in an
interview yesterday Al Roker said that
during a visit to the White House quote
I pooped my pants
yeah he's the first person to soil his
pants at the White House since that time
Hillary Clinton came home early and
surprised Bill
I'll be doing okay
no you can't have it both ways that way
they can throw I really disapproved
right right but loved it you're always
hearing nobody likes Congress you know
Congress is unpopular well this just
came out today according to a new poll
Congress is now less popular than head
lice Nickelback and Donald Trump in a
related story head lice is insulted it's
being lumped in with Donald Trump and
Nickelback I'm sorry I just wanted to do
my impression of angry head lice chumps
like deal with it
[Laughter]
in California in California thieves
broke into a Microsoft Office and only
stole the Apple iPads yeah today a
spokesman for Microsoft said they're not
just thieves they're also dicks that's
so depressing yeah you didn't want on
our windows no we're good we're fine